mation nouvelle de cette matinée c'est
le lancement d'une seconde étude
consacrée au cancer de la prostate et de
son probable lien avec la chlordécone
oui mais une étude en guadeloupe et
pourtant c'est bien la martinique qui
détient le triste record mondial du
cancer de la prostate pire le plan mahdi
prostate a été clairement annulé alors
pourquoi ne pas le relancer à la place
de carles prostate 2 nous n'aurons pas
la réponse du préfet franck robin n'a
pas répondu à la presse ce matin
quoi qu'il en soit pour le président de
l'assemblée seul compte
l'objectif visé par caru prostate de
l'essentiel c'est que déjà ils nouvelle
étude soit lancée
je pense que de plus en plus aux verts
on va cibler de manière plus précise
le lien de causalité c'est ça qui est
important il est manifeste ce lien mais
enfin il faut qu'il soit prouvé
on en tirera toute une série de
conséquences prouver que la chlordécone
est responsable du taux explosif de
cancer de la prostate aux antilles et
peut-être d'autres cancers
c'est la volonté de la majorité de ces
élus des élus qui ont globalement
apprécié l'intervention du préfet l'ont
jugée positive mais ils attendent aussi
des actions concrètes le préfère donner
des informations on ne les connaît pas
tout mais il va falloir que l'état
débourse puisque c'est vrai qu'on est en
période de restrictions budgétaires mais
c'est un un problème sanitaire grave qui
va falloir régler puisqu'il va de la
santé des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais l'état n'a pas toujours eu
une attitude exemplaire un dans la
question de la cour d'école mais qui
viennent pour subir un cette séance de
questions directes des représentants des
martiniquais c'est une bonne chose
c'était quand même un échange qui me
semblait intéressant en tout cas qu'on
se rencontre et qu'on passe le sugen
façon commune on ne peut pas simplement
laisser l'état en charge ces questions
le député du sud à lui jeté un pavé dans
la mare en dénonçant un nouveau scandale
celui de l'asie locks et pour lui azou
locks et chlordécone c'est tout
simplement criminel pour protéger et
pour privilégier des intérêts financiers
on n'a pas appliqué un principe qui est
important c'est le principe de
précaution on a mis en péril la santé
d'une majorité de toute la matinée
qu'une majorité de nos compatriotes et
c'est pourquoi je considérais j'assume
le terme de génocide par empoisonnement
c'est un terme qui est tout à fait
fondée et légitime alors à qui la faute
pour le président du conseil exécutif la
ctm ne doit pas être un bouc émissaire
la responsabilité de cet empoisonnement
est pour lui très clair dans la lutte
contre les conséquences sanitaires de la
chlordécone les élus territoriaux ont
tous semblé unis mais monsieur qui se
déchire au sein d'une même famille
politique
parfois on peut dire les mêmes choses
afin de marie jeanne et moi dans deux
styles différents
donc on est peut-être complémentaire à
quelque part